- Il y a 75 ans, un géologue
canadien lance une idée
révolutionnaire: que la Lune
est un morceau de la Terre
arraché lors d'un impact
d'une violence inouïe.
Début 20e siècle : la Lune
est un monde encore rempli
de mystères.
À preuve, quand le cinéaste
George Méliès prend la tête
d'une expédition vers la Lune,
son imagination est
sans limites!
La Lune cache bien
des énigmes. En particulier,
celle de savoir d'où elle vient.
À l'époque, plusieurs idées
circulent sur son origine.
Notamment, que la Lune était
un astre errant, attrapé au vol
par la gravité de la Terre.
L'autre théorie en vogue,
c'est que la Terre, lors
de sa formation, tournait si
rapidement, qu'elle a projeté
une partie d'elle-même
en orbite.
Ce sera la source d'inspiration
du Canadien Reginald Daly.
Mais il calcule que
la rotation ne suffit pas.
Il imagine un scénario
catastrophe.
Au moment où la Terre est
tout juste formée, une
mini-planète la frappe
de plein fouet. Du magma
s'envole dans tous les sens.
Puis, les morceaux s'attirent
entre eux, pour former la Lune.
Daly s'appuie notamment sur les
photos disponibles à l'époque.
Il analyse minutieusement
les cratères, leur taille
gigantesque, la hauteur
des parois, les projections
tout autour.
Il en déduit que ce ne sont pas
des volcans comme on le croyait
mais les cicatrices d'impacts
à sa surface.
Et il a parfaitement raison.
Mais il va un peu trop loin,
en concluant qu'il s'agit des
derniers morceaux de la Terre
à avoir rejoint la Lune.
On sait maintenant que les
cratères ont été formés sur
des milliards d'années, par
des comètes ou des astéroïdes,
qui ont frappé la Lune.
Pour le reste, les hypothèses de
Reginald Daly seront confirmées
par les missions Apollo.
Les roches lunaires, récoltées
par les astronautes, sont très
semblables à celles de la Terre.
Elles ont la même origine.
Les 12 hommes qui ont marché
dans les traces des explorateurs
imaginés par Méliès n'ont pas
trouvé dans les cratères de la
Lune des champignons énormes,
ni le palais des Sélénites.
Mais plutôt les indices, des
événements d'une rare violence,
qui ont sculpté ces paysages
lunaires, d'une beauté
à couper le souffle.